regardez chef de la résistance
martyrisée dans des caves leadeuse
regarde de tes yeux disparu toutes ces
femmes noires qui veillent nos
compagnons elle porte le deuil de la
france est le tien regard de glisser
sous les chênes vins du quercy avec un
drapeau fait de mousseline nous et les
maquis que la gestapo ne trouvera jamais
parce qu'elle ne croit qu'aux grands
arbres regarde le prisonnier qui entre
dans une villa luxueuse et se demande
pourquoi on lui donne une salle de bain
il n'a pas encore entendu parler de la
baignoire comme leclerc entre à aux
invalides avec son cortège d'exaltation
dans le soleil d'afrique entre ici jean
moulin avec toro terrible cortège